thank you so thank you very much to the
organizers for organizing this and for
inviting me
um
so i only asked for a half an hour
because i was assuming that some of the
ring lwe background would already be
given
and given the
late starting time of this talk i'll try
to go as quickly as possible through the
through the background
so this is a bit of an abbreviated title
i did have actually a title and an
abstract that i sent maybe a little bit
late but it didn't appear on the on the
website but it's um supposed to be
attacks on the decision version of rlwe
so this is joint work with yara elias
and aiken osman and kate stang which
will appear at crypto 2015.
so the first thing i want to tell you
all in case you're
so it sounds like a pretty bold title
right a tax on our lwe so you probably
most of you probably know
at least in recent years what i've been
largely working on is practical
applications of homomorphic encryption
so for example my talk at eurocrypt was
all about practical applications of
homomorphic encryption so one takeaway
that i can tell you right to begin with
is the attacks i'm going to tell you
today do not threaten homomorphic
encryption schemes based on cycloatomic
fields where you take two power
cyclotomics
so as far as we know unless these
attacks are extended in some way the
attacks i'm talking about today do not
uh undercut our current implementations
and applications of practical
homomorphic encryption which is good
news from my point of view um but this
line of research we're diving into in
order to better understand whether there
are additional attacks that could
threaten it so practical homomorphic
encryption schemes which we've heard
about several times over the last few
days
based on work proposed by gentry and
then brakerski and vaikatunathan and
brakaski gentry viking
et cetera et cetera so there's a number
of different
practical homomorphic encryption schemes
that are in use today for all kinds of
great applications so applications
basically to cloud storage and services
including things like privacy for
electronic medical records private
predictive analysis doing kind of
machine learning on encrypted data
genomic computation on encrypted data
which there was a very high profile
contest this spring
um for for this so homomorphic
encryption has been um one of the very
nice motivating
applications for using lattice-based
crypto
and we heard an extensive talk on
history uh yesterday from danielle so i
don't have to go too much into this this
was just kind of an abbreviated version
the i thai dork public key crypto system
from around um almost 20 years ago the
entry family of cryptosystems proposed
by hofstein pifer and silverman
the actually these were actually
standardized in around 2008
the the
kind of new hardness assumptions take
new with the grain of salt here i mean
new meaning over the last five to ten
years
uh new compared to rsa for example uh so
new hardness assumptions um that make
some of these lattice uh crypto systems
possible
the learning with errors and the ring
learning with errors
learning with errors originally proposed
by reg f and ring learning with there
was proposed by lubizewski pykert and
regiff and related security reductions
that have been proved to hard lattice
problems gap svp and bound to distance
decoding and such
so this is all um
been contained in kind of the
introduction
introductory talks that you'd heard
yesterday and and this morning and um
this morning we also heard more about
the ring lwe
um distribution and ring lwe problem
from from damia so let me just quickly
review this so so don't even look at
this slide right this is a lot of words
and a lot of terms right what is ring
lwe
you take a secret
in this case the vector can be thought
of as the coefficients of a polynomial
so just think of it as a secret
polynomial
you've got you're going to generate a
bunch of random samples what are you
going to do you're going to generate the
secret is s you're going to generate an
a which uniformly at random multiply a
times s which is the analog of doing the
inner product in the vector space
setting and then you're going to add
some errors so that's what the ring
learning with errors is just the
learning with errors in the ring setting
which means given a bunch of kind of
inner products that have been obscured
with a small error
can you find the secret
so you've given some some number of
samples in order to do this so the ring
setting you can do it either in a ring r
or in its dual and in this talk mostly
for simplicity we're going to focus on
doing things in the ring
so the search problem is what i just
said finding s given a bunch of samples
the decision problem is just given a
bunch of samples can you decide whether
they are lwe samples or not
and the hardness comes from so in the
ring setting this theorem of lubashevsky
picard and rega from 2010
which basically
says that
if you
if you consider
a large enough error that there's a
polynomial probabilistic polynomial time
quantum reduction
from the
approximate svp sivp problem
in on ideal lattices to this rlwe
problem
so in addition to this hardness result
for
rlwe there's also search to decision for
search rlwe there's also search to
decision reductions proved in p lpr for
cycloatomic fields and extended um in
joint work with eisentrager and halgren
for to apply to all galwa fields
so this is again this is everything i've
just said is stuff that had been said
already
but now i'd like to focus on
something that was discussed in detail
in damian's talk this morning
so the way i liked about to think about
it is is that you have
these two embeddings what what damian
called sigma sub c and sigma sub p
and this is kind of a key point which is
that
for these proofs of security proofs of
hardness for uh you know the
foundational results you have
you consider the embedding of this ring
where you're going to do ring lwd you
consider this an embedding of this ring
into the
complex numbers in a particular way so
the usual um
minkowski embedding just takes any
element of a number field and sends it
to all of its
algebraic conjugates
and this is
a slight variation on this um
the usual minkowski embedding uh was
defined in lpr and called the canonical
embedding so there's just a small
difference there so you take this ring
and this is um the thing that i think
roughly is what
damian called sigma subsea this morning
and the nice thing about putting this
ring inside here so that you get a
lattice is that then all of these
hardness reductions can take place and
you can talk about the hardness of the
rlwe problem
as being related to these hard lattice
problems
but now there's another important
consideration which is that for practice
for actually deploying cryptosystems
what we really do is we think of some
polynomial basis
for our ring
which is given by
some irreducible polynomial f of x so f
is going to be irreducible so this is
what was called sigma sub p
so the main thing that i'd like to
highlight here with this slide is you
call the i call it the p i
i'm sorry i don't call it the plw
problem this was called the plwe problem
by rockerski and vaikatunathan
in their um crypto paper in 2011 and
related to
the work of lpr 2010
and this plwe problem is basically
do the same as rlwe but do it in this
ring so what is the difference the only
difference is
the generation of the error so here just
think of the error distributions as
being these kind of spherical gaussians
and here they're again like spherical
gaussians but they're being selected
coordinate wise
where the basis
so if this ring is
written as z of beta it's generated by
beta which is a root of f
this has a basis which is just 1 beta
beta squared up to
beta to the n minus 1.
so the plwe problem is kind of and you
could call it an instance of the rlwe
problem you could call it it was
originally called a variant of the rlwe
problem in bv11 but in any case it's the
same idea
where you generate samples as follows
there's a secret and there's a
kind of an inner product plus an error
but the error is now generated component
wise according to this basis and this is
what we do in practice when we deploy
practical homomorphic encryption schemes
so the plwe problem is obviously
important to consider them since that's
actually what we do
and so you might say well why don't you
just generate the error here where
you're supposed to and then push it over
here and the answer is that that's ex
one answer is that that's expensive
another answer is that yeah maybe we
should do that and then a third answer
is that if you stick to two power cycle
atomic fields it doesn't matter you have
an isometry that maps
if you look at the the image here of r
and the image here of r
and you take the change of basis matrix
you have an orthogonal scaled matrix
which maps the one basis to the other
and so it simply doesn't matter you can
do it either place and so that's why the
moral of the story from my point of view
is is that
the clearly safe thing to do is to just
stick to two power cycle atomic fields
because there are these distributions
are the same no problem
so then the question is
what happens if you don't stick to two
power cycle atomic fields so i'm going
to i'm going to leave the case of
non-two power cyclotomics as an
intermediate
question
to be considered later but just in
general think of a number ring so and
you want to do rlwe
or for example if you're going to use it
in practice you actually want to do plwe
so what we did in the paper with
eisen traeger and holgren was to show
that
in general for a lot of rings there are
attacks on plw
so this is how the attack works
um so
basically
like the easy way to say it
is that you're going to take a rlwe or
plwe sample a i b i
so what that means is that
bi is of this form it's a i times your
secret plus e i
and e i has been selected with small
coefficients in this basis so it's a
polynomial but with small coefficients
here from in this basis
and so what what will happen if you um
look at this
product at the
input one so you have a i and bi they're
polynomials you can evaluate bi at one
you can evaluate you know a i so you can
evaluate a i at one and
you don't know the error but if the
error polynomial has very small
coefficients and it's evaluated at one
it's going to be very small
so the fact is is that all of the
multiplication takes place in this ring
which is our mod
if this is r
the multiplication of polynomials takes
place
in
our mod qr
so when you take these two polynomials
if you write coset representatives for
them
so this is all happening you know modulo
this polynomial f of x
and if f of one is actually equal to
zero mod q
then when you do this multiplication you
will get the same thing as if you had
just taken a i and evaluated at one and
take an s and evaluate it at one because
each of these is just you know a i plus
some multiple of f
times s plus some multiple of f but f at
one is equal to zero mod q so it goes
away
so if you um
if you have this condition
that you chose a q
such that one was a root of f
mod q then
you can
conclude that bi at one will just be
equal to this
quantity
and what you can do is just
evaluate bi at 1
subtract off ai at 1 times a guess for s
and there are q possible guesses for s
so this is very similar to the
attack that was
mentioned this morning for
bad cases of um
of uh
like even
ring sis where if you just took x minus
one was a factor of of the polynomial
there if you didn't have it irreducible
but here the difference is is that one
the polynomial f is irreducible but it
just so happens to have one as a root
mod q
so
if your guess for s is correct then your
you will be looking at the evaluation of
the error polynomial you have a bunch of
samples so what you can do is just start
with one sample
go through until you find a guess such
that the error looks small if it is
small keep that guess
and
when you go on to the next sample only
check the guesses that you already kept
from the previous one very quickly
you'll see whether you find
one of the guesses that's correct or not
so um
this is the attack on the the plwe
problem
and so what i wanted to kind of
summarize here what's this might not be
the most interesting perspective for
this crowd but from a number theoretic
point of view what we've really done is
to say
oh hey listen here's some interesting
properties of number fields
because if you have all these properties
for a number field you're going to have
certain conclusions for cryptography
so what we did in eisentrager and
halgren
in the paper with them in sac last
last summer was to enumerate six
properties of number fields so first
property is whether
um q splits completely
and if the if actually if the
if the ring is actually monogenic
then you don't even need this condition
because this will just be equal to one
so the second condition is whether the
number field is galwa
third condition is whether it's
monogenic this property is is called
monogenic that means that this is
actually equal to
the ring of integers in the field not
just a sub ring like we were discussing
this morning in dummies talk
the fourth property is that this
transformation if you look at the
transformation matrix so now i'm going
to write that
matrix
is the change of basis matrix between
these two settings
so and that in the paper with
eisentrager and hollgren we
required that that transformation matrix
be basically an orthogonal scaled matrix
the fifth property is the one that we
needed for the attack
and the sixth property is just q being
large you know for applications to
crypto so unfortunately in that paper
we couldn't find number fields
satisfying all six of these properties
at once and we still don't have any
satisfying those are hard some of those
are very hard conditions to satisfy for
example just taking galwa and monogenic
together the only known families
so for example the only
monogenic and cyclic galwan number
fields are the real subfields of the
cyclotomics that's it there are no
others if you take monogenic and galwa
is you're very very restricted there's
not that many
the monogenic is
maybe not entirely needed but let me
tell you why these six conditions are
needed conditions one and two
are for the
the known search to the decision
reductions now that doesn't mean that
these search decision reductions can't
be extended
but at least for now under those
conditions that search the decision is
known
for three and four
that's where we're able to have a
reduction between the plwe and the
actual rlwe
instances and for five and six that's
what we need to have a meaningful attack
and you need to have q large enough to
be kind of interesting for crypto i mean
you can still do it with small q but
nobody would use it in practice
so um we don't have um number field
satisfying all six of these properties
so um and i'll just give you the nice
example that we know and love which is
the two power cycle atomic fields those
satisfy all five properties except for
the one that you need to attack it so
very nice very convenient for us
um so um i'm going to skip over that in
the
interest of time
so since we can't find number fields
that satisfy all six of those what can
we do so what we did in the current work
with
elias and osman and stang was to
first of all try to relax some of these
conditions so the most important one
that we wanted to relax was this
condition of on the change of basis
matrix and not requiring basically that
you have an isometry between these two
images but instead saying well
what is the change of basis matrix and
what does it do to the error and from a
kind of linear algebra
point of view this is a very simple
question and we have a quantity that is
it was defined probably more than 100
years ago i don't even know when it was
defined called the spectral norm
and it just is for a like a change of
basis matrix it measures if you have the
unit ball in the in the one space which
is kind of what you're interested in
small error
and then you apply the change of basis
matrix the spectral norm will give you
the radius of the ball that the image
lies in so that's kind of very clearly
what we're interested in here how much
does the error get distorted if you move
from one to the other so the moral of
the story is
that if we focus on examples where you
have small spectral norm then you're
very likely to be able to relate
instances like samples here to
legitimate samples here and and vice
versa
so um
the other thing that we wanted to do was
to extend the attack so that you don't
have to have one as a root of f mod q
but you could have other things so for
example suppose that f has a root beta
mod q
which has a
small order mod q so what does that do
for you so beta could be very large it
doesn't have to be one or two or three
or something like that it can be a large
number but what this says is its powers
hit very few elements mod q if it has
small order so if you look at the error
polynomial look at the values that it
can take when it has small coefficients
well
there's n powers of beta that are listed
in there but they're not all different
there may be only like two or three
different values so the set of values
that the error polynomial can hit is
small and you can enumerate them and
then test for that condition whether
you're in that set of values for the
error polynomial
so um that was kind of the extension on
the um
ehl attack that we introduced in this
paper and this is
um this relaxation of that condition was
enough for us to extend
and find examples where we can actually
attack our lwe
so in the
roughly 10 minutes that remain
what i want to do is tell you kind of
what we were able to find in what we
present in this paper so roughly um
the list is let me see i'll
come back to this
so basically we're able to construct
examples of weak rlwe fields weak plwe
fields we're also able to construct
weak
two power cycle atomic fields even but
just with a different basis not the
basis that you would normally use
um we present code for the attacks and
we also present heuristics on spectral
norms
which allow you to kind of make a
general prediction about how often
number fields would be susceptible
to this type of would would have
basically would have small norm here
and then we also give a bunch of kind of
interesting new questions and number
theory that come up from considering
this line of attacks
so um let me go back through the first
maybe you might consider the most
interesting
um
thing is to
look at the construction of the family
of number fields for which rlwe is easy
to attack
so
this condition on being
monogenic is is not absolutely necessary
but what it does is it allows you to
move back and forth between the ring and
the dual
ring version of the problems so it
depends kind of on how much you care
about that
the second condition is um the crucial
one f of one is congruent to zero mod q
third condition is this rho is going to
be our spectral distortion
and sigma is the is the error
so i think i define row somewhere
one of these slides somewhere in here
anyway sorry rho is the spectral
distortion
so
if you for example i didn't say this but
if you want to compute the spectral
distortion you can compute it as the um
the largest singular value of this
matrix so it's not hard to compute but
if n is very if the dimension is very
large it can be computationally a little
bit expensive to compute that
okay so the main theorem that applies to
this construction is that
if the spectral norm
is
smaller than this quantity
then we
expect
to be able to
attack the rlwe decision problem
with this probability in this amount of
time where l is the number of samples
so
you can see how it
scales with the number of samples that
you need
and the family is exactly constructed so
that when you add one you will get zero
mod q it's very easy so um you need a
few conditions because
this needs to be
irreducible in order to define a number
field
and
this is going to be true whenever
q minus 1 has
a prime factor that appears to exponent
one
we also need a few conditions so we
construct it so that
okay so this is a little bit bad
notation because
this is just an auxiliary prime whereas
l down here is the number of samples
but we need to construct it so that
it's both monogenic and irreducible so
that's what these conditions are for
and this condition is in order to make
the spectral norm small enough
so if we construct it which we did we
found examples of this kind
so that all these conditions are
satisfied then you can attack rlwe and
these on these fields and i'll give you
some concrete running times
at the end
so
um how do we select parameters both for
deploying
homomorphic encryption schemes and also
for demonstrating attacks
well the funny thing is is that if you
look in the literature over the last
five years primarily people seem to have
followed the recommendations in lintner
pikert so linder pikert from rsa i don't
know maybe 2012 something like that
11 yes gave
a bunch of security levels high medium
and low
and suggested
parameters for example high security
like n is 320 q is 2 to the 12 and sigma
is
8. there's a difference in the
literature some people would call this
sigma equals three like two to the third
so it depends on how you're defining
sigma here but so for those parameter
choices for example the distinguishing
attack is estimated to run in time two
to the 122 with a distinguishing
advantage of 2 to the
minus 64. so
if you look there are at least
three or four maybe even more by now
kind of open source or at least publicly
known implementations of
the these homomorphic encryption schemes
and
if you look at the parameters that have
been selected for example a very very
typical parameter set is something like
n is 10 24 and q is like 2 to the 128
something like that that's if you stick
with two power cycloatomics
so our um
i think you can see from that
that for for a lot of homomorphic
encryption applications q will be very
very large
and again when q is large you don't care
that much about this attack right this
attack runs in time o of q because you
have to say you have to go through all
the guesses
mod q
this attack makes a lot more difference
when you're considering
much smaller parameter sizes which are
things like
i mean we've seen already a couple of
examples in different talks of much much
much smaller parameter sizes where q is
small if q is 2 to the 32 likes been
suggested for a tls like key exchange
then the attack is perfectly
you just do more reasonable to get a
smaller q yeah we keep talking about
that we haven't figured out like
kind of
everybody says that reaction but we just
kind of don't know
so this is an attack on on rlwe oh go
ahead your f is tuned to q right your f
has q in it
um this particular
family does but in general it's any
number field
such that one is a root or such that
beta is a root mod queue
yeah but so typically
like if you're going to attack a real
system there's going to be some
you know n and q that were chosen
and the question is so so how do you do
so now you want to do a modulus
switching attack so you're going to
switch it to the queue where you think
you can attack it
so
i just don't know
yeah
so i'd be happy if we could make that
work but we were discussing it over
lunch with damian
and
like the two power cyclotomics the
reason that the attack doesn't work is
that the only q
possible is q equals two
and we and so can you modulus switch
down if your modulus switch down to q
equals two you can attack that one too
yeah
that's that's right
okay so here's some concrete attacks so
here this is a very typical size this is
these are the parameters that are
suggested for key exchange for like tls
for example
and if you look at um
uh samples um generated randomly for
this problem so what we do in practice
we generate a bunch of samples using a
secret
we pretend that we have forgotten the
secret we run our attack and then we
check whether we found the secret or not
and
in this case the attack ran in 13.5
hours
so that's pretty good for this parameter
size
if you look in these are much smaller
levels uh
i mean they're probably relevant for for
applications like signatures and things
but these are typically
way too small to be used for homomorphic
encryption applications
and these the attack runs in like 25
seconds
um so the interesting thing here is that
um
like here's the number of samples that
were needed like 20 samples
and the um the standard distribution of
the error i should have called this
sigma probably
is is in this column
and
this tau is the quantity that i defined
earlier
so
here these attacks are working even
though this towel is pretty small
so the towel basically the smaller it is
the harder we think it will be to attack
but we're already you know we're still
successful with towels that are
relatively small
so it's interesting because like if you
bump up the error that's just going to
make your towel a little bit smaller
so this border of how small tao can be
and we still
succeed is is really important
but we're we're succeeding with taos
that are much smaller than where we
expect to to be able to succeed already
on all of this was run with the sage
mathematics software so i think i'll
just close by mentioning some of the
interesting number theory problems that
are introduced by this
for example like what are the spectral
distortions of algebraic numbers so i
talked about spectral norm over here if
you just think of the algebraic number
beta
and call its spectral distortion the
spectral distortion of this change of
basis matrix
an interesting thing that we've noticed
is there seems to be a correlation with
algebraic numbers that have small molar
measure which is something that's
studied extensively in number theory so
small spectral distortion could be
related to like there's extreme examples
of number fields with small mahler
measure that looks kind of like an
interesting connection here's this
question that's been studied over time
by many people which is
can you construct fields which are gawa
and monogenic
other than cycloatomic number fields and
their real
subfields
things like what are the distribution of
elements of small order mod q
and then finally things like so like
what is the smallest uh residue modulo
prime which has exhor
order exactly ours a more specific
version of this and an interesting
number theory connection here is is that
typically
people think about the art and
conjecture which is what is the smallest
residue which has like the full or full
group order like the generates the whole
group so it's kind of a flip it's like a
reverse of the art and art and
conjecture here so one reason that i
like to mention this last slide in
addition to the obviously interesting
cryptographic
aspects of this
talk is is that i think that
investigating these attacks brings up
lots of interesting new questions in
number theory which will hopefully keep
lots of number theorists busy for a long
time even completely independent of
crypto applications so thank you very
much
any questions
what's so special about one is it enough
to have a small root curve
for all of this to work yeah but if you
have even two
then the error polynomial has you know
the degree is n so it already has 2 to
the n in it so 1 or minus 1 is fine
but
then even once it's 2 then it's going to
be very very hard to
so distinguish so so if i understand
right the
the like pick your favorite one the
first version of the distinguishing
attack that so you have a case where
this m matrix is
pretty close to an isometry i mean it's
not too
crazily distorted or anything like that
and
you have a distinguishing attack
um
so so geometrically things look like
they like they should i mean like if you
were to view everything in the canonical
embedding it would look pretty much like
it's supposed to
you can distinguish
um
any thoughts on on search or or
what do you think is happening there
well so
oh i guess the one thing i didn't
mention i meant to it was on my list was
is that um we know that we have the
search to decision reduction when you
have the galwa thing which is
essentially what was explained this
morning by damian with the automorphisms
when you have the automorphisms then you
can move things around
but we we don't know um search to
decision reduction
you know for a larger class of fields
yet but we do we did some kind of
heuristics on like how often we thought
that the
spectral norm would be small
and heuristically it looks like a large
percentage of fields would
fall susceptible to this and so then if
you believe that like say gawa fields
are randomly distributed among fields
then you would think there would be some
fields in the intersection that you
would have somewhere you would have both
the search to decision reduction and the
attack on the rlwe problem
so i mean we certainly have the cases
of the plwe attack plus the search to
decision that we know but we just don't
have the relationship like the even the
two power cyclotomics that have a
different basis
so um yeah so you you can attack them
and they're gow wow you have a search to
decision reduction but it that you can't
relate it to the usual rlwe because the
just the the arrow gets sent all over
the place
so when you look at the change of basis
matrix are you looking at the condition
number so
it's close
no it's related to the condition number
but spectral distortion is not exactly
the same
so
this small spectral distortion
necessary for this attack to look for
well so i think of it very naively
you're given a bunch of rlwe samples and
then if you want to use the attack you
push them over here into plwe samples
if the error doesn't get distorted too
much then the attack will still succeed
if there's a spectral distortion is
large it seems to me very likely that at
least one of the coefficients will get
you know will be quite large
so
is one of the coefficients being large
enough to kill the attack
you know
we don't know
we just know for sure that if it does
stay small then we will succeed
is there a is there a
like a
interpretation of what's happening
up above instead of pushing it down into
the plw is there an interpretation of
what's happening in terms of
the ideals factor or something
well okay so i'm if you mean okay so q
what we're assuming here
is that
f does
uh
split mod q right or at least it has a
factor here which is saying that either
q is you know split in this ring or
for example one of the we think we might
be able to extend the search to decision
reduction to cases where it doesn't
split completely but it splits into
other ideals
of um the same degree where you the gala
group acts transitively anyway or
something like that um so i'm i'm not
sure if that's what you meant but
for this
for this attack we're assuming that we
do have at least a root mod q
which means for example
q is not inert in this ring
um